[Musique]
je suis juste venu dire au revoir
je suis malade
je veux pas que je sache
dis-lui que tu ais je sais tu veux que
je t'appelle papa ou est ce que je dois
dire tout simplement eaton
c'est pour moi ouais il est super violet
oui c'est ta couleur préférée quand
j'avais 9 ans oui s'aliter tu crois pas
que zoé a le droit de profiter de son
père plus que deux ou trois malheureux
moi je veux que tu bosses pour mille en
échange des services de nettoyage
je t'offre un traitement expérimental
qui pourrait bientôt rendre ta petite
vie à toi de choisir tuer ou mourir tu
as vraiment arrêter travail hébreu
pourquoi tu nous a laissés maman et moi
voyagez beaucoup chimie
les gars
sebbar
pourquoi ta mis tout ce temps leur
revenir ça n'a rien à voir avec toi
hop
j'ai fait des choses qui sont
impossibles à expliquer
tu penses que papa va rester aussi
longtemps qu'elle le pourra